good afternoon my fellow 2015 I'm John
Scott one of your class marshals and it
is my absolute pleasure to be
introducing the next speaker the one the
only Ethan
Gabriel LOI so Ethan first walked into
my life at the onset of sophomore year
one of my block mates decided to take
time off at the last minute so my
roommates and I thought we had somehow
beaten the Dunster housing system and
we're already making plans to make and
transform this coveted extra room into
the best bomberman videogame suite you
have ever seen this side of the
Mississippi but Ethan here this tall
random tall kid from Colorado waltzed
right on into a 33 and dropped his
luggage down smack-dab on top of our
dreams and aspirations of creating the
ultimate man cave
however family and friends of the class
of 2015
do not fret for this tale first world
woes does indeed have a happy ending
unbeknownst to us we did win the housing
game we got anything
and let me tell you this guy is
incredibly talented so I'm ecstatic that
you will all be getting a glimpse at one
of Athens many gifts before piecing out
of here but what's even more impressive
to me beyond his skill as a writer is
his willingness to make himself
vulnerable and try new things despite
any lingering fears or apprehension and
so without further ado please put your
hands together and welcome to the podium
Ethan Louie
ariana grande once said don't ever doubt
yourself or waste one second of your
life it's too short and you're too
special powerful words but I'm not just
here to bombard you with incredibly
profound quotes in fact I'm actually
here to disagree with miss grande though
it pains me to contradict such a
prominent cultural and intellectual
leader at first glance her quote seems
like a harmless collection of graduation
speech cliches believe in yourself
you're special you are all going to be
President but let's take a closer look
at this gem of wisdom through the always
helpful lens of academic analysis miss
grande makes two normative statements
that I would designate as potentially
problematic firstly that life is too
short and secondly that we are special
maybe it's too long and we're not
but I'd like to overlook these concerns
for now to get to the most troubling
piece of mis Grande's advice don't ever
doubt yourself don't ever doubt yourself
first of all it's not realistic advice
I'm sure that every one of us in our 40
years at Harvard has come to know
self-doubt maybe we were unsure of our
niche in the vast Harvard ecosystem or
what career path we should follow after
graduation maybe the doubt itself became
a source of anxiety that we strove to
silence to find airtight confidence and
a straightforward path through life
rather than struggle with the
frightening and ambiguous challenges
that self-doubt can present as graduates
of a place like Harvard this type of
evasive overconfidence can sneak up on
us we're young we're successful we have
society stamp of approval everything's
going right for us so we must be living
our lives the right way but this
closed-minded deterministic thinking
while it can bring us comfort can also
blind us to meaningful introspection all
too often we associate doubt with a lack
of courage or confidence but today I'd
like to argue just the opposite I think
that to doubt yourself in an honest and
unsparing way actually requires courage
to question your path through life at
age 22 or 52 is an act of humility that
I hope we will not abandon the second we
win our first paycheck or first award
self-doubt is more than just a growing
pain or fixture of your final year at
college it's something constructive
something illuminating that can guide us
at any stage of life now just for the
record yes I am aware that graduation
speeches are supposed to be uplifting so
if all this talk of doubt is bringing
you down I want to clarify the following
friends classmates comrades you are
wonderful and talented individuals but
as young Harvard graduates we have no
shortage of people telling us that we
are great and while each and every one
of us deserves the strength of
self-belief let's try to balance it with
the perspective of self-doubt now my
personal balance has always been
weighted a little more heavy
towards doubt which is an understated
way of saying that if competitive
neuroticism were an Olympic sport I
would be it's Michael Phelps but
ultimately I'm grateful for my ability
to question myself doubt can feel like a
burden but I believe it's a burden worth
carrying one especially positive aspect
of doubt is that it helps us think
through our decisions and we've all had
to make some big ones lately about where
to go and what to do and why senior year
is a time of tremendous doubt for many
of us and in the crucible of all that
uncertainty it is so tempting to choose
the safest or most popular options
presented to us to make the low risk
decision rather than the one that is
true to our passion and ideals we've all
faced some very enter this challenging
crossroads personally I've long wanted
to be a teacher or maybe a writer but
ever since my freshman year a great
number of people from friends to family
too drunk strangers on airplanes have
told me that I should become a lawyer
Ethan they'd say you're moderately good
with words you have a loud didactic
voice so it's settled I never wanted to
be a lawyer but the pressure came from a
lot of places the aforementioned drunk
strange anonymous drunk stranger on an
airplane even told me the by comic by
becoming a teacher or a writer I would
be wasting my Harvard diploma but he
then proceeded to open up SkyMall and
order a set of matching beer cozies so I
think I can take that opinion with a
grain of salt and yet despite having
little passion or ability for it I
almost applied to law school I had taken
steps towards becoming a writer but no
one was offering me a book contract and
I was so petrified of being seen as a
failure that I almost accepted a career
I knew was not right for me simply
because it felt safe as I learned from
this experience
some people have implicit assumptions
about what Harvard students should do
with their lives certain predetermined
paths to a predetermined image of
success and in the stressful
tumultuously of senior year
it's easy and tempting to ignore our
doubts and just go with the flow to be
overwhelmed by the comforting allure of
money or prestige and my fear is
certainly not that we will sell out that
would be an unfair judgment to make
everyone needs to pay the bills and I'm
sure many of us will go on to be great
philanthropists but I worry that by not
sufficiently questioning our path
through life we may struggle to find
lives of joy and purposeful work as a
member of the class of 2015 I've seen
firsthand just how smart and capable you
all are and how driven you are to make
the world a better place which is why I
would hate to see even one of us get
stuck doing work we don't believe in it
now again to be clear I'm not saying
there is anything wrong with being a
lawyer or banker or consultant or any
job that falls under the umbrella of
lucrative and prestigious the world
needs talented good-hearted people to do
these jobs but let's doubt the
assumption that the most lucrative
prestigious path is necessarily the best
path for us above all let's pursue our
prospective careers because we find them
meaningful and I don't presume to tell
you what makes a career meaningful I
merely ask that we ask and ask
rigorously don't repress your doubt
confront it and if you haven't found
your purpose yet keep searching because
it is better to struggle with tough
existential questions than to come up
with forced or unsatisfying answers and
better to fail in pursuit of a worthy
goal then succeed in achieving a hollow
one class of 2015 we have every reason
to believe in ourselves but let's not be
afraid to question ourselves as well
doubt has helped me find some
perspective on my future maybe it can do
the same for you because we are all just
searching for a meaningful path through
life and if we keep asking questions
I am confident not doubtful that we will
find it Thank You classmates Thank You
Harvard I love you guys
you